hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren
ich habe mir gedacht ich spiele heute
mal das spiel moneygram weil das also
erstmal mein nachbar hat heute wohl die
kunst des presslufthammers entdeckt und
spielt damit zurzeit irgendwie so ein
bisschen um wahrscheinlich werde ich es
hinkriegen das ganze audiospur nachher
zu berichtigen dass ihr das nicht hören
können aber trotzdem könnte er mal damit
aufhören müssen sich vorstellen kleinen
luca schläft wacht auf 5 uhr fängt er an
also lasst euch davon nicht irritieren
also wir spielen heute das spiel mit
niegripper und zwar handelt dieses spiel
quasi von meinem leben man muss quasi
einfach seinen arm ausstrecken und nach
geld greifen was vom himmel fällt
ich hab den charts noch nie gespielt wir
klicken einfach mal auf play touchscreen
reicht es nicht ich kann es nicht halten
ich kann nur einmal einmal drücken und
muss dann immer so ganz kurz drücken
oder einmal ganz ich kann auch ganz
durch drücken der ist ich muss ich muss
das ist ja das ist ja mega easy und ich
sag immer schreibt ihr mich spielen die
kommentare meistens wurde echt so
unseren schwarzen gewünscht sehr viel
wird auch gleich oft einst gewünscht
monster legions wurde sehr oft gewünscht
das werde ich vielleicht bald auch mal
anprobieren und dieses spiel wurde zwar
nicht gewünscht aber ich dachte es wäre
schwer aber es ist nicht schwer
was ich wollte einhändig mache und dann
geht's nicht 23 dollar bis zum nächsten
preis man kann also preise kriegen
na das ist doch nicht war und jetzt
fängt er da wieder an zu hämmern du okay
wir konzentrieren uns jetzt darauf und
werden selbstverständlich einen neuen
highscore schaffen mit meiner nase nein
bisher womit man [ __ ] kriegen kann
zwei dollar mit der nase verdienen um
geld geld geld geld
übrigens könnte dann einfach das ipad am
drucker anschließen und euch alle münzen
oder diamant alter der hat mir grad
einfach 50 dollar gegeben also ihr könnt
natürlich das ipad wenn ihr wollt
einfach an drucker anschließen und dann
könnt euch das geld ausdrucken sage euch
mal wie das geht gleich okay dieses
spiel ist voll mit features ich habe wie
fünften mal 250 dollar
was ich hab nicht ich habe aber wer
einen preiswerten preis jungs achtet wir
haben vielleicht ganz eventuelle lücken
neue ford ka jo das heißt kase jungs
egal wir kaufen uns das erstmalig auch
dass es so wie mit need for speed die
haben zwar richtig geile autos du weißt
was das bei autos sind aber die dürfen
einfach die richtigen namen nicht
benutzten express die karte zeigt die
richtige uhrzeit an dem echten leben ist
kein wirklich 16 16
man denkt an mich läuft dollar bis zum
nächsten preis das muster nein durch die
nato wieder ran hallo geld achtet screen
jetzt nasa us dollar
234 ich sehen diamanten jemand in ein
mikro you can you glasses dann setzten
uns mal brille auf ich hab so habe ich
mein hobby ist ein mikro gerade
eigentlich irgendjemand ipad das hast
dich richtig das hat sogar schon dadurch
dass das teilweise echt hinschmeißen dir
das da da sind einfach so kratzer drin
dadurch dass sich das teilweise wirklich
echt ich nehme das der luft aufnehmen
kann das hat durchsicht der teilweise
bauweise sind da einfach so richtig
tiefe rillen und kratzer drin ich weiß
ja hallo sieht man dass das einfach so
rené kracke keine ahnung woran das liegt
es kann sein dass hier auch mäuse sind
oder irgendwie oh es geht weiter es gebe
aber meine zunge ist das stark und hat
mich gefragt wie man in geld ausdrücken
kann und zwar ich mach das jetzt mal
ganz einfach dass ich hier erst mal kurz
verliere so ich habe jetzt einfach gar
kein geld gekriegt aber jetzt kann ich
hier in diesem mit screen einfach ionen
draufdrücken und jetzt drückt er hier
auf drucken und jetzt funktioniert es so
etwas auch mega cool ist diese app man
kann hier einfach mal drauf klicken hier
und dann ist man im real life mode und
dann kann man ganz einfach man die
gräber in real spielen kann
ok
ich hätte erstens nie gedacht dass ich
so viel scheiß kleingeld in meinem
portemonnaie ab und zweitens hätte ich
nicht gedacht dass das so läuft das ist
die rache die schönsten nach wahlwies
falls ihr euch fragt warum mich wo zwei
euro sind weg hat sache freunde waren
übrigens an alle die sich fragen wie man
schreibtisch aussieht hier lerne ich
immer für ordner hinter weiter da sind
auch lernen sagt hallo scheiß kamera
dass man auch lernen sachen also eine
salat schale eine flasche wasser aber
das hier ist der ganz anderes von von
mir womit ich aufnehmen und so aber zwei
euro viel reis etwa auf mein cruz valdez
drauf ich glaube ich soll heute nicht
aufnehmen alles mögliche fällt hin alles
fällt runter ich mache noch einen run
und die dann mache ich ihnen helfen
ich mach den highscore übrigens noch mal
alle die mir nie zu hören und sage hey
mach doch mal flugmodus an dann hast du
nicht die ganze werbung da oben freunde
seht ihr das ich bin über wlan mit dem
dingen verbunden das heißt ich brauche
internet das heißt sie kann kein flug
modus drei machen aber dass gerade ich
will dass sein team mit einem kabel dran
fakten weil damit sonst könnte ich halt
nicht so machen und auch hier hinten
spielen seht ihr das nicht
von ihr hinten spielen so richtig
behindertes video alter die ads also nee
ich bin einfach den ganztag am leeren
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich mach
dann kleine äpfel sache und so die mich
eigentlich immer meisten zeit mit
bearbeiten kostet aber naja wenns euch
gefallen da würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr weitere app
scannt die spielen soll schreibt für die
kommentare wenn ihr denken kumpel
gefällt das video dann teilt es ihm
macht alles was man mit dem video machen
kann lag das ab was weiß ich keine
ahnung und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder